Continuing in Hilchos Milah, Yoreh Deah, siman Reish
Samech Vav. We are up to Sif-Ches, and
this is another super exciting Sugya regarding Yom
Tov Sheni Shel Galuyos. So by way of
preview we have to go back to Sif-Beis.
In Sif-Beis we learned Mila Docha Yom Tov
VeShabbos Bizmana. If it's a Mila Bizmana, the
eighth day, we know that it's Docha Shabbos
and docheh Yom Tov. we do the Bris
on Shabbos, we do the Bris on Yom
Tov, Aval Shelo Bizmana, but if the Mila
is Shelo Bizmana, Eina Docha. So
even if it's about Mila Shelo Bizmana, if
it's not the eighth day, so it's not
Docha Shabbos and it's not docheh Yom Tov.
On this Eina Docha, there should be a
little Beis. That little Beis takes us down
to the Gilyon Maharsha. So we're in Sif-Beis.
In Sif-Beis there's another Sif-Katan Beis in the
Gilyon Maharsha and the Gilyon Maharsha gives us
a preview of coming attractions, Eina Docha. So
Mila Shelo Bizmana is not Docha Shabbos, not
docheh Yom Tov. What about Yom Tov Sheni
Shel Galuyos? Says the Gilyon Maharsha Sif-Katan Beis,
VeYom Tov Sheni Docha LeDa'as HaRambam. According to
the Rambam, Mila Shelo Bizmana is Docha Yom
Tov Sheni. VeHaRosh Savira Lei De-Eina Docha and
the Rosh holds that it is not Docha
Yom Tov Sheni. So we have a major
league Machlokas Rambam-Rosh, is Mila Shelo Bizmana Docha
Yom Tov Sheni? The Rambam says yes, the
Rosh says no. Why the Gilyon Maharsha put
it over there is not so clear to
me, the Sugya is over here in Sif-Ches.
Now, the Sugya in Sif-Ches starts from the
Mishnah in Shabbos Daf Kuf-Lamed-Zayin. There the Mishnah
tells us that a Katan is Nimal LiShmona
LiTisha LaAsara LaAchad-Asar ULeYwais-Asar. The baby has a
Bris on the 8th, 9th, 10th, 11th, 12th
day. And then the Mishnah explains: Nimal LiShmona
Kedarko. Normally the baby is supposed to have
a Bris on the 8th day. LiTisha, that's
if the baby's born Bein Hashmashos, Safek Monday,
Safek Tuesday, so we don't want it to
be on the 7th day, so we have
to err on the side of caution, so
we do it on the 9th day, meaning
it's a Safek 9th day, Safek 8th day,
we're calling that the 9th day. If it's
Bein Hashmashos Shel Erev Shabbos when the baby's
born, then the 9th day is Shabbos and
it's Safek if it's a Mila Shelo Bizmana.
So therefore we can't do it on the
9th day, maybe the baby was really born
the day before and it's the 9th day,
it's not Mila Bizmana, it can't be Docha
Shabbos. So therefore the baby, the Bris is
LaAsara, is on Sunday. If Sunday is Yom
Tov. then the Bris will be ULeAchad-Asar, it
will be on the 11th, we'll push it
till after Yom Tov. And then the end
of the Mishnah ULeYwais-Asar BiShnei Yamim Shel Rosh
Hashanah. If Sunday-Monday is Rosh Hashanah, so then
the Bris is going to be pushed off
until Tuesday, and that will be 12 days
possibly after the birth of the baby. The
baby again we're talking about a baby that's
born Bein Hashmashos. So it's Safek 11, Safek
12, we're calling it 12. Let's see that
now in Shulchan Aruch. Says the Shulchan Aruch,
Yoreh Deah Resh-Samech-Vav. Sif-Ches: Mi SheNolad Bein Hashmashos
SheHu Safek Yom Safek Layla, Bein Hashmashos is
Safek Yom Safek Layla, between Shkia and Tzeis
HaKochavim, we'll discuss that more in the next
Shiur. Safek Yom Safek Layla, Monim Min HaLayla.
So we count, we pretend, we do Ke'ilu
the baby was born at night, VeNimal LaTshii,
and the baby's born nine days from the
day. Because SheHu Safek Shmini, the 8th day
from the night. We'd rather do 8, Safek
8, Safek 9 than Safek 8, Safek 7
because we already discussed how complicated it is
for the baby to have a Bris before
the 8th day, so we'd rather do Safek
8, Safek 9 than Safek 7, Safek 8.
Ve-Im Nolad Erev Shabbos Bein Hashmashos continues the
Shulchan Aruch. Now it's Erev Shabbos Bein Hashmashos,
so Eina Docha Es HaShabbos, SheEina Dochina Es
HaShabbos MiSafek. As a Safek, it can't be
Docha Shabbos. The Bris is going to be
pushed off till Sunday. VeChen Eina Docha Yom
Tov MiSafek. It can't push off, the Bris
is not Docha Yom Tov. MiSafek either. Ve-Afilu
Yom Tov Sheni Shel Galuyos. Even Yom Tov
Sheni Shel Galuyos you can't do the Bris,
you have to push the Bris off till
after Yom Tov Sheni Shel Galuyos. The Mechaber
here Paskens like the Rosh. Look
at the Shach Sif-Katan Ches. veafilu Yom Tov
Sheni shel Galuyot, velifi aniyas da'ati, ikkar k'haRambam
de-docheh Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot. The Shach
disagrees with the Mechaber. The Mechaber paskins like
the Rosh. No, bris shelo bizmanah on Yom
Tov Sheni. Shach says the ikkar is like
the Rambam and it is Docha Yom Tov,
Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot, velifi aniyas da'ati,
ikkar k'haRambam de-docheh Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot,
ve-chein hu gam kein da'as ha-Smag, ve-hakabbalah, ve-chein
hu da'as ha-Bartenura she-peireish shnei yamim tovim shel
Rosh Hashanah di-kdusha achas hein. When it's shnei
yamim tovim shel Rosh Hashanah, it's not Docha
like the Mishnah said. It's not docheh Yom
Tov Sheni shel Rosh Hashanah, but it will
be docheh Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot. Look
at the Biur HaGra. Biur HaGra siff katan
yud-daled. veafilu Yom Tov, u-mah shekasav be-masnisin Yom
Tov Sheni shel Rosh Hashanah. That sounds like
only Rosh Hashanah but not Yom Tov Sheni
shel Galuyot, says the Gra, no, that's not
a diyuk mishum de-masnisin nishnis be-Eretz Yisrael. The
Mishnah was taught in Eretz Yisrael and there
is no Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot. And
that's why it says Yom Tov Sheni shel
Rosh Hashanah. But i hachi nami chutz la-aretz
even Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot is not
Docha like the Rosh and the Mechaber. That's
shitas ha-Rosh aval haRambam kasav de-docheh Yom Tov
Sheni shel Galuyot. Now to properly appreciate this
sugya, we have to understand that there's two
different scenarios where a bris shelo bizmanah would
come out on Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot.
The case of the Mishnah is that the
baby's born on bein hashmashos of Erev Shabbos.
We can't do the bris the next week
on Shabbos, even though that's the eighth day,
that's when it should be, but it's Shabbos,
so we push it off to Sunday. Sunday,
Monday is Yom Tov. so we can't do
it on Sunday, and we're discussing doing it
on Monday which is Yom Tov Sheni shel
Galuyot, two days of Sukkos, Shavuos, whatever it
is. That's one scenario. Now there's another scenario
where the baby's born bein hashmashos and we
said it's supposed to be, we're going to
count the eighth day from the night which
the Mishnah calls the ninth day, and the
ninth day turns out to be Yom Tov
Sheni shel Galuyot. In the first situation, the
ninth day turns out to be Shabbos and
then you're doing the tenth day, eleventh day,
we're danim on the eleventh day, we say,
maybe it's a machlokes Rambam Rosh if you
push it off to the twelfth day. That's
what the Mishnah says and the Mishnah talks
about two days of Rosh Hashanah. What do
we do about Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot?
But what the Mishnah does not discuss is
what if the baby's born bein hashmashos and
the ninth day is not Shabbos and it's
not Yom Tov but it's Yom Tov Sheni
shel Galuyot? In that case it could be
safek tisha safek shmona. So in that case,
maybe everyone will agree that the bris is
docheh Yom Tov, Look at Rebbe Akiva Eiger.
Rebbe Akiva Eiger siff katan hey. veafilu Yom
Tov Sheni shel Galuyot, lichora kasha ha havei
sfek sfeka, safek zemanno ve-safek she-hu yom chol.
keivan de-hu Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot, right,
Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot, right, we don't
know which is the proper, which is the
real Yom Tov So maybe it's Yom Tov.
maybe it's not. But even if it's Yom
Tov, maybe it's the eighth day and it
is docheh Yom Tov, So we have a
safek if it's the eighth day or the
ninth day, and even if it's the ninth
day, maybe it's a yom chol because it's
a safek Yom Tov safek chol. It's Yom
Tov Sheni shel Galuyot. That's the question of
Rebbe Akiva Eiger. You can do the rest
of Rebbe Akiva Eiger for homework. So these
are the two different scenarios that we are
discussing within doing a bris quote-unquote shelo bizmanah
on Yom Tov Sheni. Is it mamash shelo
bizmanah and that's a machlokes Rambam Rosh and
Mechaber Shach? Or is it safek shelo bizmanah
because baby's born bein hashmashos and what the
Mishnah calls the ninth day is Yom Tov
Sheni shel Galuyot, and then you have a
sfek sfeka says Rebbe Akiva Eiger and a
good reason to do the bris on Yom
Tov Sheni even according to the Mechaber. Look
at the Pis-chei Teshuva siff katan zayin. Yom
Tov Sheni shel Galuyot ayin be-Birkei Yosef beshem
Shach ve-ayin bi-teshuvas Noda bi-Yehuda chelek Orach Chayim
siman lamed she-he'erich be-zeh ela de-mah she-kasav ha-Mechaber
ve-chein be-Yom Tov Sheni shel Galuyot. When the
Mechaber says the bris is not docheh Yom
Tov Sheni shel Galuyot, kavanasso im hu vadai
shelo bizmanah like the case of the Mishnah,
kegon she-nolad be-erev shabbos bein ha-shmashos u-ve-shavua she-le-achar
safek shemini chalu shnei yamim tovim shel galuyos
be-echad be-shabbos u-ve-sheni be-shabbos she-nimol le-yom yud-bais. That's
the case of the Mishnah. Baby's born Erev
Shabbos bein hashmashos and then you can't do
it on Shabbos, so you push it off
to Sunday, Sunday's Yom Tov... And so you
can't push it up to Monday, Monday's Yom
Tov sheini shel galuyos, and you're going to
push it off till the day after, because
that's vaday shelo bizmano. Aval mi she-safek shemini
shelo b'Yom Tov sheini, and the Noda Biyehuda
held even in Rosh Hashana, that's
controversial, not everyone agrees with that, nimol b'sheini,
then the bris will in fact be on
Yom Tov sheini shel galuyos. De-hava safek sfeika,
shema hayom zmano, maybe today's the right zmano
because the baby was really born at night.
V'im timtza lomar eino zmano, and even if
it's not the proper zmano, shema hayom chol,
maybe it's really chol, v'lo hava davar she-yeish
lo matirin keivan d'chazar l'issuro, we're not going
to get into that right now. Continues the
Pischei Teshuva, v'chasav od, le-inyan plugta she-bein ha-Rambam
v'ha-Rosh, bi-mila vaday she-lo bizmanah im docheh Yom
Tov sheini shel galuyos, nireh ikar k'ha-Rosh, the
ikar is like the Rosh, like the Mechaber,
d'ein docheh. Mi-kol makom, mi she-rotzeh lismach al
ha-Shach she-hichriya k'da'as ha-Rambam, ein mochin b'yado. Someone
wants to be someich on the Shach and
the Rambam, we're not going to stop them.
Ayein sham. Continues the Pischei Teshuva in the
brackets, v'ayein bi-teshuvas Chasam Sofer siman reish-nun she-he'erich
b'inyan zeh v'he'elah be-hachlet le-hachmir k'ha-Rosh. Ha-halacha is
like the Rosh, like the Mechaber, no option
to follow the Shach. U-k'haskamas ha-Tashbetz, she-ra'ah divrei
ha-Rambam v'ha-Smag, and he rejected the Rambam and
the Smag, v'hiskim im ha-Rosh. V'ha-Shach lo ra'ah,
teshuva l'ha-Shach lo ra'ah teshuvas ha-Tashbetz. V'chol heicha
d'divrei rishonim ne'elmu m'einei acharonim halacha k'rishonim, whenever
the acharonim didn't see the rishonim, so we're
going to go with the rishonim. And the
Shach didn't see the Tashbetz. Ach, bi-safek im
ha-mila hi hayom bizmano, nireh li k'ha-Nodeh Biyehuda
ha-na'al. But when this day, Yom Tov sheini
shel galuyos is a safek yom shemini, so
then we will do the bris on Yom
Tov sheini. Limol b'Yom Tov sheini shel galuyos
al kol panim, v'lo m'ta'amei d'Nodeh Biyehuda mishum
d'hava safek sfeika. Says I don't like the
reason of the Nodeh Biyehuda safek sfeika, I
have a different reason. Rak mi-ta'am acher, d'asi
safek kiyum mitzvas asei d'Oraisa of mila bi-zmanah
on the eighth day, v'dachi, and it's going
to push away the safek kal d'Rabanan of
Yom Tov sheini. U-vifrat idna, nowadays that we
really know what the right day is, and
Yom Tov sheini eino ela minhag. U-masik, the
conclusion of the Chasam Sofer, she-ha-zariz u-meikel b'Yom
Tov sheini u-machmir l'molo b'yomo, who's machmir to
do the bris on Yom Tov sheini shel
galuyos when it's a safek shmona, b'yomo safek
shemini safek tshi'i, harei hu min ha-zrizim, that's
the proper thing to do, says the Chasam
Sofer. Okay, then he brings down another teshuvas
Chasam Sofer in two teshuvos later, reish-nun-beis. Before
we did reish-nun, reish-nun-beis, gam kein teshuva me-inyan
zeh v'sham ein da'ato kein. Here he has
a different opinion. Ela d'afilu sfeika eino docheh
Yom Tov sheini shel galuyos, he changes his
mind. Ach kefi ha-nireh, says the Pischei Teshuva,
lo nidpas al ha-seder. These teshuvos are not
written in order. It should be, it looks
like reish-nun and later comes reish-nun-beis. Reish-nun he
says do the bris on Yom Tov sheini,
reish-nun-beis says don't do the bris on Yom
Tov sheini. No, it's out of order. V'osa
teshuva d'siman reish-nun-beis she-nidpasa rishona, it was printed
first and it comes first in the teshuvos,
hushav b'achrona. He really responded to reish-nun came
before reish-nun-beis, b'erech esrim shana v'yoser, at least
20 years later. Min ha-kosev al shaar ha-sefer
v'habu chazei, v'hi ikar d'ikar. Teshuva is the
first one not the second one, the first
one came at least 20 years later where
he chazar bo and he held like the
Nodeh Biyehuda but from a different reason, that
if it's a safek shemini, the bris should
in fact be done on Yom Tov sheini.
So bottom line, if it is a vaday
mila she-lo bizmanah, so then the poskim say
not to do the bris on Yom Tov
sheini like the Mechaber and the Rosh. That's
Rav Shloime Zalman, Rav Elyashiv, Rav Wozner. If
it is a safek shemini, so the Orchos
also machmirim, but the consensus of poskim hold
that the minhag is that the bris will
be on Yom Tov sheini when it is
a safek shemini, either because of the safek
sfeika of the Nodeh Biyehuda or because of
the sevara of the Chasam Sofer. And that
is the psak also of Rav Shloime Zalman,
Rav Elyashiv, they bring down Rav Aharon Kotler,
and that's found towards the end of the
first perek of Yom Tov sheini k'hilchasah. In
terms of Yom Tov sheini shel Rosh Hashanah...
But there are many achronim that are machmir
that if you do Yom Tov Sheni shel
Rosh Hashanah, then it should in fact be
pushed off. Let's finish off the Michaber. Va'afilu
hotzi rosho bein hashmashos, so the baby stuck
out its head bein hashmashos of Leil Shabbos.
Af al pi sheyatzah kulo beShabbos, the whole
baby, the baby came out, the whole body
came out on Shabbos itself, Eino nimol beShabbos.
We go after the head, and the head
came out bein hashmashos of Leil Shabbos, and
therefore the bris cannot be done. It's a
safek Friday, safek Shabbos, the bris cannot be
done on Shabbos because of the safek, and
therefore the bris should be pushed off till
Sunday. Now we discussed this at length in
Reish Samech Vav Daled, exactly what part of
the head and what part of the woman's
body has to come out of, and how
much time are we talking about when the
baby's born Leil Shabbos, just a very quick
review. In Yalkut Yosef they bring down in
the month of Nissan and Tishrei, if the
baby's born in Eretz Yisroel, twenty minutes after
shkia, that that is enough to be considered
vaday Shabbos for the bris to be on
the following Shabbos. In Shulchan Shlomo they bring
down from Rav Shlomo Zalman, that in Nissan
and Tishrei it is twenty-five minutes after shkia.
In the winter it's a little shorter, they
bring down twenty-two minutes, in the summer a
little longer, twenty-eight minutes, and when I called
one of the poskim in America, so he
wanted to say that in New York area,
fifty minutes, if the baby's born fifty minutes
after shkia, that's for sure considered born on
Shabbos, even if you're makpid on Rabbeinu Tam
to end Shabbos seventy-two minutes. And if it's
a bit less than fifty minutes, it sounded
like it depends on when you finish Shabbos.
If you finish Shabbos forty-five minutes, so then
if the baby's born forty-five minutes after shkia
on Leil Shabbos, that would be considered Shabbos,
vaday Shabbos, and the bris can be done
on Shabbos. So that is your daf, no,
Siman Resh-Samech-Vav